Hello ! We all need wedding cakes !
Must be three lucky men ! Who's got a picture ?
You guys realize that's the same guy right? Oh, don't be silly
Son aren't you tired of being hated by every man in the land
He stole my love !
I do like being adored by the ladies though
No lady who gazes into the eyes of the prince will be able to resist his smile
On his 21st birthday this blessing curse will be sealed
And all love will die !
That's in 3 days
Prince Charming it is time to choose your one true love and liberate all others from your spell
Piece of cake , kiss me now and save us all .. does this normal work for you
Only with any other lady in this land
Wow well that was different
So determine which of these three princesses is my true true love the fate of my entire kingdom
Depends on it. Your kingdoms in luck because I can take you to that we leave at once ... oo heyy? ;)
I feel so alive
What is your plan true true love must be earned by running the gums of three impossible tasks
across the impossible paths
Two ! Survive an unsurvivable attack we're dead hello there you tell a cat little flowers
And 3 !
Let's do this !
Well that played out differently in my mind
You